if there's one thing that can get a
company absolutely destroyed on the
internet it's investing into nfts and
crypto riot games had to practically beg
for forgiveness and so did dead by
daylight people just hate the blockchain
despite all this one company that has
managed to not only rebrand itself using
the blockchain and still be able to
expand is facebook now named meta meta
ceo mark zuckerberg recently announced
that they were expanding their high tech
menlo park campus in silicon valley the
campus was already impressive to begin
with and so here's your exclusive look
into meta's massive headquarters
location
facebook or meta's headquarters lies in
menlo park on the edge of san francisco
bay spread out over 250 acres with over
30 buildings the entire complex includes
everything the employees might need to
get their creative juices flowing it's
more of a town instead of a tech company
campus the headquarters is a 10-minute
drive from the menlo park caltrain
station and regular shuttles are also
part of facebook's plan to help their
employees get to work more easily the
campus has tons of parking space too if
the employees want to drive to work
however employees have also been
allotted a transportation stipend so
they can take advantage of the public
transport system the team
more than 12 000 employees almost a
quarter of meta's entire global
workforce work at the menlo park meta hq
the team at menlo park is responsible
for a bit of everything engineering
communications and most importantly
virtual reality are all departments that
the menlo park team is actively focusing
on the virtual reality department
recently got a very big boost after
meta's metaverse announcement and is now
one of the most active departments at
the company the departments are arranged
pretty randomly so employees have to
pass different ones thereby increasing
chances of socialization apple does a
similar thing which they say helps give
rise to new ideas and promotes
innovation speaking about innovation
facebook has internal hackathons where
employees have to work on projects that
they don't normally work on this culture
dates back to when facebook was just
started and mark zuckerberg was hiring
and promoting employees based on the
winners of hackathons pretty cool huh
these hackathons are what resulted in
the development of the news feed feature
which now exists across pretty much all
social media platforms facebook might
have grown into a multi-billion dollar
company but they haven't yet let go of
the out-of-the-box approach that got
them there for a company named facebook
they're really not doing things by the
book i mean it's meta now but you get
the point unlike traditional
corporations that have gray lifeless
cubicles meta lets its workers customize
their workspaces and offices as much as
they want an employee of the company was
reported saying we try to hack our
spaces and no that does not mean that
they are hacking their computers that's
the job of the fbi it means things like
personalizing their desk by hanging a
pride flag from a banister or even going
as far as to add a full arcade in their
closets sounds a bit far-fetched well
what happened is that one of the
employees decided he wanted to play
games during his free time and brought a
japanese game on campus one day this
game was installed in his closet yep you
heard right other employees thought this
was a great idea and before you know it
the entire closet was a makeshift arcade
one guy even had a dance dance
revolution machine installed although
i'm not really sure how that would fit
in a closet what i'm trying to say here
is that facebook or well meta gives its
employees the power to do what they feel
would be helpful to them this lack of
micromanagement gives more control to
the employees and shows them that their
management trusts them now i'm going to
guide you through some of the other
highlights of the meta menlo park campus
so buckle up 1. main street
facebook decided to ditch the bench and
eye candy amusement park approach that
other companies used to swag up their
campuses instead facebook decided to
take a bit of inspiration from the
nearby palo alto main street and come up
with a main street of their own this
main street houses several cafes
eateries and even a health and wellness
center in case someone needs to go to
the doctor or grab some meds the main
street is also where most of the
employees hang out between meetings and
hang out with their colleagues you know
how some of the best ideas you get are
while eating good food well that's
exactly what facebook is banking on this
main street also makes the entire campus
look more like a small town rather than
a conventional corporate office it is
also what led to the start of open space
offices and tech companies now i've got
a cool little fact for y'all facebook
was the largest open space styled office
at the time of its new office's
commencement now let's go to
2 rooftop park
the mpk 20 has been embellished with the
additional feature of a 12.6 acre
rooftop park in zuckerberg's own words
frank gehry designed a palette of colors
and bands across the roof the lush lofty
park sprawls over the entire roof and
it's a soothing reprieve for employees
who often jog through the greenery
during their much needed blue light
break some of the best features of this
elevated garden include 90 native fauna
like the resident and migrant birds
hundreds of desedicious and flowering
trees over 150 thousand native shrubs
and a one-half mile long gravel pathway
not only that but the rooftop park also
has been tastefully adorned with gary
design tepees beautiful art
installations and swanky lawn furniture
lastly the mpk's rooftop cultivates a
strong adherence to environmental
sustainability through the installation
of solar panels these solar panels can
generate almost 2 million kilowatts of
electricity each year which is more than
enough to power 70 000 homes per day if
that's not impressive i don't know what
is metta actively encourages its
employees to go for walks on the rooftop
and has retrofitted the rooftop with
whiteboards and wi-fi to further boost
employee productivity research has
proven that walks surrounded by nature
boost creativity and apparently mark
zuckerberg himself uses this tactic to
get ideas he has given several
interviews on the rooftop and often
takes a walk there
3. freebies
who doesn't love freebies zuck knows
just how much people love free stuff and
the menlo park campus has tons of them
there's a free arcade system which has
now been fully leveled up with top of
the line gaming equipment and virtual
reality headsets food is also free
throughout the campus and last but
definitely not least is the free laundry
service meta has partnered with purple
thai to offer its employees free pickup
and delivery laundry service this
according to chloe myers a senior meta
employee is to make people's lives
easier the real treat however is the
culinary selection the campus offers
food from all over the world
remember how when men in black agent j
and k go for pie and it helps them save
the world well that's just the power of
good food in a relaxing environment
something which the aromatic biryani
scent you can find near the menlo park
cafeteria is trying very hard to prove
the menlo park campus with all its
impressive qualities would seem
incomplete without the addition of good
food to make sure this doesn't happen
metta has added culinary options from
all over the world in their campus from
simple stuff like a good cup of joe to
ethiopian and mexican delicacies meta
has tried to be as meta as possible to
make sure the environment is as good as
the food is it is rumored that the chefs
play ethnic cultural music matching the
locality of the food they're serving
that day that's not all much like their
strict adherence to privacy laws meta
has adhered to the rule of always giving
their best at least when it comes to
food art museum
frank gehry was involved in designing
the buildings of metta's menlo park
campus and was in one of these buildings
their in-house artist-in-residence
program led by guggenheim alum tina vaz
this program has placed 15 art
installations within the building the
most famous of these installations
consists entirely of recycled computer
parts like key caps and motherboard
fragments the artwork has been made to
look like tree roots and is inspired
from california's redwood forests leave
a thumbs up if you enjoyed the video
also a sub to the channel would be
monumental
see you in the next one